The second official trailer for "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage" has finally landed,
and we've been treated to a
heaping serving of new content.
There are also a few hidden easter eggs that
are fun to dissect, so let's take a look at
the small details you may have missed in the
second "Venom: Let There Be Carnage" trailer.
During the trailer, Eddie Brock sits
down at his desk and looks at a Daily
Bugle article on his computer, where Cletus
Kasady is making headlines for his crimes.
While he looks over the report, some drawings
are scattered in front of him on his desk.
Written inside the trunk of
a large tree are the words
"to thee the strife was
given between the suffering."
Poets and literary enthusiasts will recognize this
as a part of a stanza in
Lord Byron's "Prometheus".
"Prometheus" is about the Greek Titan of the same
name. Known as the God of Fire and a trickster,
he often helped humanity by stealing fire and
giving it to humans. A traitor to the gods,
and a friend of humans, Prometheus
was punished by Zeus for his "crimes."
The poem primarily focuses on what happens
when one resists tyranny and how powerful
that is. It'll be quite interesting to see
how this quote directly connects to Cletus,
as well as why it's something that
Eddie appears to be analyzing.
The new trailer also references The Daily
Bugle, Marvel's most famous in-universe
newspaper. Since Peter Parker and Eddie Brock
both worked for the company in the comics,
it isn't surprising that the sequel
calls back to the publication.
Detective Mulligan is reading a copy of
the paper in the first trailer, and the new
footage shows Eddie working on his exclusive
interview with Cletus Kassady for the Bugle.
"When I get outta here, and I
will, it's gonna be carnage."
The layout of the paper's next edition is
shown on Eddie's laptop, using the same
logo design as the Sam Raimi "Spider-Man"
trilogy. But the paper's masthead also
reads "West Coast Edition," so clearly the New
York-based outlet has expanded across the U.S.
This honors Eddie's comics backstory
while also keeping him away from New
York so that Sony doesn't have to
explain where Spider-Man is yet.
Aside from all the Symbiote shenanigans, the
trailer also gives fans a better look at Naomie
Harris as Shriek, locked up in the Ravencroft
Institute for the Criminally Insane before Woody
Harrelson's Carnage breaks her out. Harris briefly
appeared in the first trailer for the sequel,
which showed Shriek's glowing eye as
she's curled up in her Ravencroft cell,
but this new footage gives us a better look at
her ear-piercing powers. The villain unleashes
a devastating scream in a car, smashing
the windshield. This is probably after her
escape from the institute since she's still
dressed in the same white detention outfit.
Shriek is a mutant in the comics,
but it's not clear if this version of the
character will have the Mutant Gene/X-Gene
in the "Venom" sequel because Marvel Studios
now holds the rights to mutants and the X-Men.
Shriek's eye is also glowing bright blue as she's
screaming in the new trailer, which could actually
be a nod to another surprising ability she has.
Not only can she unleash a sonic scream, she
can draw out someone's inner darkness using her
"Dark Empathy" which causes her victims to commit
unspeakable acts. Since she'll be partnering up
with Woody Harrelson's Carnage, it wouldn't be
surprising if she helps turn San Francisco
upside down using her manipulative skills.
In several trailer scenes, Eddie Brock
is seen wearing a tee-shirt underneath
his jacket that reads "Mumford Phys. Ed.
Dept." Fans of "Beverly Hills Cop" should
recognize this shirt immediately, as Eddie
Murphy wears a similar shirt in the R-rated
'80s film. Murphy's character Axel Foley is an
alumnus of the real-life Detroit high school,
and he wears a white and grey
version of the shirt in the film.
In fact, "Beverly Hills Cop" producer Jerry
Bruckheimer graduated from the school as well.
The directors of "Beverly Hills Cop 4"
revealed in 2017 that they would love
to have either Hardy or Channing Tatum as the
sequel's main antagonist. Is this Hardy's way
of telling us he's been cast or is interested
in the film? Probably not, but here's hoping.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.